[Music]
black pinks how you like that racked up
86.3 million views in its first
24 hours and now fans are getting a full
length album from the k-pop powerhouse
group
you guys have been gifting us with
singles and hit songs and music for a
while now but
what does it feel like to finally be
able to release a whole body of work
that's representative black pink to your
fans
um it's surreal it's surreal
and it's a very nervous and exciting
um emotion just going up and down from
us we just wanted our fans to
um just enjoy which one whichever one
that you like
because we have everything ready for you
you have a little bit of black paint
yeah definitely
i was one of the lucky few that was
actually in the crowd during your
coachella set
and i still think about four minutes
when you look back
at that performance in particular what
does it mean to you now it's definitely
a moment that we'll never forget
um it was one of this
important steps that we took last year
to
um make us into a better artist
and a better selves and like i
personally
feel like i was so much confident after
performing at coachella
because of how low my expectations were
for like myself too
you know because i knew how nervous i
was i didn't think that i would go up
and
be like i think yeah
you know even like today i i cannot go
back and watch that video because i can
see how excited i am
in the video you're cool we're really
really thankful for the opportunity that
um we had to go on and perform at
coachella and
still we're so happy about it it's a
life-changing moment it was a
life-changing moment for the people
watching too and they were all like
rocking out that's so nice to hear i
mean that's
kind of what we live for and obviously
since
that moment at coachella for all of us
it's been quite the year
you know um obviously we are still in
the for most of us in the middle of a
global pandemic
what did you guys do during that time
were you tweaking the album or did you
have some down time to kind of just do
what you wanted to
as soon as things kind of cleared out
over here we were back in the studio
being creative
creative as ever and i think it gave us
a big boost
for us to be kind of back into work mode
because you know
you know that time is very difficult for
everybody else to
and hopefully we kind of um went dived
into the album hoping that this would
come out
as more of a hope for our fans to listen
to we do know that
things are still going around what is
your favorite song on the album like
what song
on this record means the most to you
that's the hardest question
i'm very excited for our fans to hear
lobster girls um
title song because um i feel like we
showed
like the black side with how you like
that and the pink side with ice cream
so they're probably wondering like oh
where are they gonna go from here
but i feel like we we chose the right
song to go with
um for the title of our album
um because it has our like ourselves
into
the song and it has a great message that
we all
really relate to and we like so yeah
we're excited for
all types long the album also features
two collabs
bechawanna with cardi b who told fans on
twitter the song
is amazing and ice cream with selena
gomez
[Music]
did you guys see her trying to learn
your choreography she i feel like she
nailed it what'd you think of her dance
moves
so adorable she did a great job with
that yeah i mean i was surprised
it was so cute yeah um it would have
been
like a lot of fun if we actually got to
do
that practice together but just
um just watching her clips made us happy
and
i guess um our friends felt that too
we were very grateful that she was very
down to kind of
explore the kind of music and the kind
of things that we do too
and so very grateful for that and we
feel like she really helped us out a lot
in that collaboration you can tell she
wanted to make you guys proud um and i
have to ask because
selena has a new cooking show are any of
you guys cooks like what do we have to
do to get you guys to
now you know pay her back and be on her
show oh
[Laughter]
yeah probably not much to show but we
would love to on day your netflix
documentary i got a chance to watch it
and it was amazing because you get those
behind the scenes moments of coachella
the lady gaga track but you also learned
so much about each of you guys
individually
um and also just how dedicated you are
to your craft
how excited are you for fans to see a
more vulnerable side of black pink
because you guys really let it out there
it was the right time for us to share
that
um share those moments yes
with our fans because um in the
beginning
of our debut and stuff we were we wanted
to be
very sure about the contents that we put
out
and make sure to not let anyone see our
flaws maybe
but i think we've come to a point where
we kind of
laid back and kind of share yeah the
unfiltered real versions of us
to the world ready to just be vulnerable
and kind of just be like
this is how we started and this is why
and how we got here kind of story yeah
yeah
it was about time yeah that they get
stuff like that
you